[Music]
October is domestic violence awareness
month and safe house is here to talk
about why it is so critical to find help
and give help if you can joining us safe
house executive director Beth Flory I'm
so happy to have you here this is a
critical month we talk about domestic
violence people are aware that it's
happening and we're reporting on it all
too often why is it so important to
continue continue talking about it
so it's important to continue talking
about it one interesting data point that
I'd really like to share last year at
the end of the year agencies across
Nevada provided data about Services they
provided one of those numbers was 85 000
bed nights almost 85 000. so what that
means is that each night in Nevada last
year approximately
233 adults and children stayed in an
emergency shelter in a hotel or a motel
so that's 233 individuals that didn't go
home because they felt unsafe that
doesn't count the number of people who
maybe stayed with a family or friend or
stayed in their car or that student that
walked home to their dorm room after a
fight with their partner and it
definitely does not count all the people
who did not feel safe to leave their
abusive home I was going to say so many
don't so many are afraid to make that
call now you guys are based in Henderson
talk a little bit about what type of
service is that you provide so we
provide emergency shelter we have a
24-hour crisis hotline that victim
survivors can call anytime day or night
to get assistance we have Advocates that
can help with temporary protective
orders going to court it's so helpful to
have somebody sitting next to you when
you have to face your abusive partner
and we also have counseling services and
all of those services are free of charge
to victim survivors and their children
the first step
it is asking for that help getting that
help yes how what what are the warning
signs what are things that either you as
a victim might start to notice or you as
a friend might see what should we be
looking for so one big warning sign is
isolation abusive Partners have a
tendency to isolate you from your family
and friends we also see Financial abuse
being put down called names and then of
course that physical violence so any of
those signs where you start to feel
unsafe in your home is a good time to
call and ask for help and our hotline
operators they are very non-judgmental
they will listen to your story and they
will help you decide what you want to do
with your situation a lot of people
maybe are sitting at home and they're
thinking okay maybe I've seen this maybe
I haven't but I want to help because I
know that it's a problem what can what
can someone do you know that maybe
doesn't know a victim or a Survivor what
how can they help you so there's many
ways that you can and help we do have a
volunteer program where individuals go
through training on how to assist
victims of domestic violence in their
children and there's all all different
ways people can volunteer maybe if they
don't feel comfortable volunteering
directly with a victim Survivor they can
help with donations they can help at our
front desk any way possible we certainly
appreciate you being here on the show
and also you know being an advocate for
our people here in Nevada we know how
important it is I want to be able to
stop talking about this on the news and
I know you would probably love it if you
didn't have a job I absolutely would
love to put myself out of a job yes all
right Beth thank you so much for being
here this morning we appreciate it thank
you for inviting me
of course there are so many ways to
support safe house but there's one
tonight you can join in lots of fun a
Halloween Carnival from 6 to 8 30 at
Sunset Station the event for all ages
there's going to be games costume
contests even an ice cream bar